i hate intros the seven deadly sins
wrath of the gods ye
episode one we kick things off with the
convoy of demons that are transporting
humans to eat meliotis and bands show up
to save the people and they learn that
the villagers had fallen into a trap set
by another village nearby up on over to
the demon side of things where zeldries
informs us that esterosa was badly
wounded after the shot they had taken
from eskenore and still hasn't regained
consciousness
he also goes over the fact that gallon
greyroad and fraudrin had all been
defeated by the sins
maltspy and derrieri are still missing
after their attack on meliotis had
failed
we then meet a kid named pelio who finds
out that his father was the one that set
the trap for the captives that meliotis
and ban had set free he is working with
the demons to protect himself and his
son
when the village didn't meet the proper
quota the demon collecting the people
goes to attack the guy transporting the
captives
pillio steps in to stand up to the demon
and stop him this leads to the entire
village that was being repressed by the
demons to try and fight back against
them
clearly that's not gonna go well but
meliodas and the other sins show up to
save them
long story short fights sequence ensues
and they defeat the demons we learned
that the kingdom of leonis is peaceful
again but britannia is still dealing
with the threat of the demons and the
ten commandments
to prepare for the war against them king
bartra appoints the new great holy
knight in the weak side character hauser
episode 2. meanwhile deanne and king are
both unaware that meliodas was actually
brought back to life so they still think
that he was killed by esterosa they
separated from the others shortly after
his death and have been out of touch
living in the fairy king's forest the
giants that dien lived with had moved
into the forest as well and they're all
having a party gerhard hears the first
fairy king glock cynia's voice saying
that he is happy she is still alive
and then everybody realizes that deanna
and king are missing
they were teleported to droll and
gloccinia who have a short skirmish with
them and quickly defeat deanne and king
luxinia then heals them and says that
they are going to train the two back
when droll was king of the giants and
gloccinio was king of the fairies they
had fought against the demons
given the circumstances at the time they
ended up joining the commandments but
now they are reconsidering their paths
glucksidia uses a spell to send them
both back
3000 years in time with king inhabiting
gloccinia's body and diane being in
droll's body they are immediately
confronted by young meliotis and
elizabeth who turns out to be a goddess
in this time the four of them go to save
a village under attack by some demons
in the last scene king and diane run
into calmadillos one of the past members
of the ten commandments
episode iii king indiana realized that
they're a lot stronger as gloccinia and
droll so they fight and
injure calmadillos meanwhile back in the
present helbroom spirit can be seen by
gloccinia and he explains that unless
they pass this test they will never wake
up
anyways back over to the fight where
king and diane get the upper hand
against calmadillos and meliotis steps
in to ks then
elizabeth uses her persuasion skills to
talk down all of the other demons and
the rest of the humans are saved some of
the people who survived wanted to join
their group called stigma which is a
three-way alliance between the fairies
and the giants who are
led by the goddesses the leader wanting
to join their group
is row and bears a close resemblance to
ban
after being accepted they all returned
to stigma's main base in the fairy
king's forest called light of grace
when they arrive they are greeted by
nero bosta and the leader of the four
archangels ludociel
of flash well talking in private
elizabeth finds out that ludociel has
made plans to eradicate the demons
she tries convincing him not to hoping
to make peace with the demons instead
but he refuses and is set on killing
them all over to gerhart who is revealed
to be gloccinia's little sister well
they're talking they see a huge force of
demons led by derriere and monspeed
approaching
elizabeth is the first to approach the
force in an attempt to prevent a
conflict fairy area agrees that avoiding
a fight would be best
as long as they hand over the captive
demons that they had taken
this cues ledocial to reveal an omega
arc containing thousands of captive
demons imprisoned in a state between
life and death
derriere has a strong response to this
because one of the captives is her
sister
he has been using these captive demons
to lure out the commandments in order to
fight them
now that they've served their purpose he
kills all of the demons sending derriere
into a rage and she punches elizabeth
because she thinks she's in on it
in the last scene we see that ledocial
isn't the only archangel who's shown up
to the fight
episode four we get the introduction of
tarmy yell of ocean who is another one
of the four
archangels and the third archangel
participating in the trap is cereal of
tornado the two arch angels summon
another omega arc destroying the entire
demon army that had showed up
in one shot only the 10 commandment
members survived the attack and
retaliate against the archangels but
can't damage them
over to ledociel who tasked narabasa
with guarding the gate to the celestial
realm since
that is where their reinforcements will
come from as he goes to join the fight
gother and moleskala
infiltrate the base and use their powers
to control narobasta
just as the commandments start getting
in some good shots ludociel shows up to
ensure that the odds stay in their favor
ludocl is by far the most powerful of
the archangels so the commandments don't
stand a chance
in order to keep up dairy airy and
monspeed sacrifice
six of their seven hearts as tribute to
become more powerful
this is forbidden magic that few know
and even amongst the 10 commandments
it's considered taboo
that's because it turns them into the
most diabolical being of all called
indra only individuals with power levels
over 50 000 can withstand the
transformation without dying the cocky
[ __ ] ledociel isn't feeling so
confident anymore after they withstand
one of his attacks
he calls out for tarmiel and sariel to
come help but they are both quickly
defeated in one attack from monsp
leaving glendale ciel on the back foot
their battle has laid waste to the land
and both sides are ready to fight to the
death until elizabeth stops him in the
last scene
episode 5 elizabeth cast the spell let
there be light on monspee and derriere
to purge them of their inter-reforms
ludociel sees this as his opportunity to
kill them so meliodas has to step in to
deter him tarmile and sariel ignore
their orders from ledociel and instead
ate elizabeth in the purifying
with all of them working together the
spell works and both of them are
returned to their original forms
again ladociel goes to kill both of them
now that they're unconscious but is
stopped by king indian getting
frustrated he then phones in help from
nero bosta and tells her to summon my
l this snaps her out of her trance and
she realizes that gother and moleskula
are there
they are in the process of transforming
the gate to the celestial realm
into a gate to the demon realm so
narrowbastic calls for help from the
humans in the fairy king's forest
as it turns out they were actually
working with the demons and proceed to
slaughter everybody nearby to prevent
them from getting to the gate
king can sense this trouble so he starts
to head back with dianne to see what's
happening
while heading there they run into gother
who is trying to prevent them from
reaching the gate also
hop on over to moleskula who has bought
enough time and has completed the
transformation
she then realizes that she had been
manipulated by gother to make her think
that she was opening a gate to the demon
realm
in reality she had actually opened a
gate to the demon realms prison
this has set gother's real body free
exposing to king and deen that they were
just talking to a doll created by him
all of his senses were connected to the
doll and was his only connection to the
outside world while he was in prison
it's been 500 years since the demon king
made him one of the 10 commandments and
put him in the demon realm prison the
reason now is the time he made his
jailbreak is to put an
end to the holy war episode 6 king
indian talk with the real gother who
tells them that there is an uprising
going on by the humans at stigma's base
the end has some more questions for
gother so king goes ahead without her
she tells him that the war is supposed
to stop today and he reveals that he
plans to put an
end to the war at the cost of his own
life he brings his doll
online and tells him that his life is
his own now meaning that he will have to
make his own decisions from here on
even though their levels of intelligence
are the same emotionally the doll is
equivalent to
a baby so he starts crying and begging
him to stay guther who knows that
diana's from the future makes the
request that when they get back to their
time deen will become his doll's friend
and be his moral compass when he goes
astray
over to gerhard who tries to reason with
roe to stop the fighting and refuses to
kill him when she has the chance
she had let her guard down while talking
to him and is attacked by another human
who cuts off her wings
and legs roue then steps in and kills
the man
in order to save her life after that she
explains that she didn't kill him when
she had the chance because she had
looked into his memories and saw a young
girl like her
he knew the girl when they were both
young but her along with the rest of his
village were killed by stigma members he
speculates that their reasoning was
because
they had found an injured demon and
nursed him back to health
king shows up and sees roe who is trying
to take gerhard to get healed
thinking that she's dead and that roe
was the one responsible he nearly kills
him but stops himself at the last second
the situation reminded him of how he
attempted to kill ban so he decides
against it rue is still killed by the
spear though and then he sees that the
real gloccinia had gone through with
killing row in the past
he then wakes up from the test and finds
gloccinia waiting for him lux and he
explains that he had killed roe back
then but even after that his grief and
pain didn't go away
instead he targeted all humans and
stigma since they didn't protect his
sister before he knew it he was a part
of the ten commandments on his quest for
revenge
meanwhile dan is still in the past world
where zeldry's had traveled through the
gate and approaches diane and the two
gothers in the last scene
episode seven zeldrace informs go
through that the demon king is pissed
that he escaped from prison and that
he's gonna have to return or zeldrice
will be forced to execute him the
end fights zeldries in order to buy time
for the two gothers to escape
once he lands a blow on her he
temporarily strips her of her power he
goes on to explain that the demon king
had lent him his power which is why he's
so strong
she is then given the ultimatum of
joining the ten commandments or being
killed on the spot
the test entails that dan must take a
separate path from drawl but also cannot
die
in order to pass this means that no
matter which one she chooses she will
fail the test
and never return to her body zildrees
also makes the observation that droll is
an
outsider amongst the giant race because
of his rare appearance
dm can relate to this because she was an
outcast also
since she didn't really like fighting
which is what the giants pride
themselves on
she then suddenly wakes back up in her
body and everybody is confused as to how
she got out of the ultimatum
turns out she just had to run away from
zelda's instead of choosing one or the
other
feel like he would have just killed her
but i'll play along out of nowhere she
gets a little hot and bothered from
seeing king
and so she grabs the little guy and
kisses half of his face
he's a bit of a [ __ ] so he passes out
but when he comes too he asks her why
she had kissed him out of nowhere she
then explains that her memories from 200
years ago of when her and king had hung
out while she was a child had returned
king was the one who had supposedly
erased those memories but as an apology
and a gift to diane
through had restored them the end
confesses her love to king and he
reciprocates this marking the star of
their unorthodox relationship now we all
know where this discussion is headed how
are they gonna [ __ ] so i did some
brainstorming and i think i have it so
hear me out first i thought king could
do some sort of diver move
using his magic to rotate himself and
sprawl his arms about for maximum
effectiveness
assuming of course that he has the lungs
for it and then i remember
that merlin actually gives her pills i
can treat her down to human size
rendering everything i just said to be
completely irrelevant but i still wanted
to share that [ __ ] up thought process
with you so you know
you're welcome we also see that king has
finally sprouted a sad excuse for wings
gerhard gets an apology from gloccinia
for killing row and then not even
checking on her to see if she was still
alive
however when oslo sees glock samia he
has a hostile reaction but he calms down
when he realizes that he wasn't there to
hurt him as it turns out gloccinia
realizes that
oslo is actually the reincarnation of
roh and he's been protecting gerhard
and king ever since dan and king have
been back to leonis in a while so they
decide to go and check in on things
king bartra had a premonition of the
sins being reunited so when deann and
king arrive using oslo's teleportation
the others are there waiting for them
this
is also where they learned that meliotis
had been resurrected dien also explains
that her memories were restored and as a
part of her promise to the real gother
she vows to return
doll gother's heart to him and on that
note king bartra makes his entrance and
shows gother that he had finally found
his missing heart
when gother sees this he has some
cryptic flashbacks and takes off running
so all the sins chase after him in the
last scene
episode 8 we learned that meliota's new
gother was a doll and explains that the
real gother was such a strong mage
even the demon king couldn't believe it
that of course led to him being picked
as the 10th commandment of selflessness
which has the ability to rob the
memories and emotions of those who
desire
guthur had made his doll look exactly
like the woman he loved but his trump
card was that he gave it a dick
so that way he wouldn't accidentally
lust after it dolgother is confused and
doesn't know why he panicked and ran
when bartra showed him the heart as
memories that gother doesn't recognize
start creeping in he labels them as a
memory malfunction and deletes his
memory now we jump back
45 years where gother still has his
emotions and heart intact this is where
he comes across the princess of leonis
and bartra's sickly younger sister nadja
they are currently in some caverns
beneath the leona's castle she was out
exploring and after talking to him for a
little bit she has to go back
well she's gone go through it realizes
that he had been asleep
since the end of the holy war that
happened three thousand years ago
and then he comes across the real
gother's body the young king bartra had
a premonition that the two would meet so
he winged man's nadja and the two of
them end up spending a lot of time
together they fall in love with each
other
but this doesn't last long as nadja
proceeds to die from her sickness
guthur is desperate to bring her back so
he tries replacing her heart with his
hoping to resurrect her which obviously
doesn't [ __ ] work guards bust in and
they think he killed her so he is to be
executed for his crimes back to the
present where diane stops him from
erasing his memories again they get into
a fight where gother realizes that she's
gotten stronger with her power level now
sitting at 15
100. king steps in and we see that his
power had spiked also
sitting at 41 600. meanwhile merlin had
studied the magic heart that was given
to him by the real gother and finds that
there is actually no magic in it at all
this means that everything that gother
was feeling had manifested itself from
him and not some sort of magic
after this realization gother regains
his original powers and memories
ye episode 9. while dealing with drunk
king we see that eskenore was given some
glasses by merlin that keeps
him from transforming until they are
removed merlin is searching for arthur
using some creepy minion with a bowl cut
named orlondi
zeldrys ends up coming across them while
they're snooping around and curses
merlin
now the gother has his memories back dan
wants to know how the real gother went
about ending the holy war but dolgother
doesn't feel too comfortable talking
about it the end also tells elizabeth
that she saw a goddess that looked just
like her 3000 years ago with meliotis
this makes her think about how kane had
told her something similar
about there being a liz from danafort
that was meliotis's girlfriend
elizabeth confronts meliotis in private
about these stories but he feigns
ignorance because he isn't ready to tell
her the whole truth yet merlin is
revealed to be getting worse
from her curse so elizabeth tries to
intervene with her healing powers she
then comes face to face with zeldries in
her mind and he tells her that she's the
cursed goddess torturing his older
brother meliotis
he goes on to explain that she has died
numerous times and every time she does
she loses her memories reincarnates and
meets meliotis to fall in love all over
again
this actually makes her happy to think
that she got to spend so much time with
meliotis and her only regret is that she
can't remember it the eldries on the
other hand
insists that she shouldn't be happy as
she has been torturing meliotis so he
returns the memories of her past lives
in hopes of her realizing how cruel it
is to him she slips away from the others
and still seems pretty happy that she's
gonna be able to remember it all
later on the sin set out to free camelot
from the reign of demons
ban is conflicted though because
moleskula is creating a barrier around
the city
if they succeed in killing moleskula the
spell keeping elaine alive will end
and she'll go back to being dead it's
revealed that elizabeth has already
started getting her memories back and is
talking about her past lives her eyes
revert back to the goddess eyes that she
originally had and then she collapses
meliotis is distraught and explains to
everybody that once her memories have
returned she will die
in three days episode 10. elizabeth
being a goddess and meliodas being a
demon had fallen in love with each other
3 000 years ago and went against their
own kind
because of this the demon king and the
ruler of the goddess clan the supreme
deity
step in to punish them they tried
fighting back but are quickly outmatched
and killed by the two rulers
or so they thought but then meliodas
wakes up and all of his wounds are
healed elizabeth on the other hand
wasn't so lucky and is still dead by his
side
while he was unconscious the holy war
had come to an end and he finds that he
isn't aging thinking elizabeth was dead
meliotis had wandered around britannia
by himself
until one day he came across the first
reincarnation of elizabeth she
of course doesn't remember him but they
end up becoming friends after confirming
that she was the goddess elizabeth when
her powers start coming back meliotis
tries explaining her past life this
triggers her memories to start returning
and she tells him that the two of them
have been cursed she makes him promise
that no matter what even if it means her
dying he will break the curse
three days later final destination takes
effect and elizabeth is killed before
she had died she explained the curse to
meliotis
meliotis has eternal life while she has
eternal reincarnation
her memories are wiped every time she
dies and when she is reincarnated she
will always without fail
find and fall in love with meliotis if
she ever regains all of her memories in
full no matter what happens or who is
around to protect her she will always
die in three days
in front of meliodus meliotis has gone
through this cycle 106 times meaning
that this is the 107th
iteration of elizabeth we see that one
of her lives had ended when she was just
a child
well another one of her lives she had
died of old age
never regaining her memories the cycle
would always repeat itself though
regardless of the circumstances
now we're going to jump ahead to the
moments leading up to the birth of the
current iteration of elizabeth meliotis
was working with merlin to find a way to
break the curse in danafor
16 years ago merlin suggests using the
coffin of eternal darkness which was a
relic that the goddesses borrowed from
the four races to
seal away the demons vic then used the
coffin to remove the goddess's seal
and release the ten commandments in
hopes of getting to zeldries who is
still wielding the demon king's power
because the demon king's power is what
placed the curse maybe zeldrus could use
it to lift the curse
meliotis refuses this idea because it
would be too dangerous and zeldrus hates
him so it's unlikely that he'll help him
however they didn't know that fraudrin
was already gathering the pieces to form
the coffin
the last thing he needed to break the
seal was the blood of a goddess but
there was none left after the holy war
fruadren tries to bypass this by
sacrificing all of the humans of danafor
as a replacement but the ritual fails
since the human blood won't work he then
conveniently runs into
liz and recognizes her as the goddess
elizabeth from the holy war
as a knight she tries to bring him to
justice but is severely injured by him
meliotis comes in just in time to
complete the cycle and watches liz die
at this point he had reached his limit
of watching her die over and over so he
loses control of his power and destroys
all of danafor
a couple days later he comes across a
woman who gives him baby elizabeth
before dying
naturally elizabeth is hoping for him to
end the curse and release him from this
eternal suffering
after story time is over everybody can
refocus on their goal to liberate
camelot from the demons
the problem is that it's guarded by the
dimensional distortion that originated
from the city of colon d
so that's where they're heading when
they arrive they find zeldry's there
waiting for them so meliotis goes ahead
to attack him
episode 11. we get a quick side story
that colin d was laid to waste by
hellbram when he was still in his human
form
but anyways zeldry's was actually a fake
to lure out meliotis
muellescaled then uses her cocoon of
darkness to separate him from the others
while searching for meliotis the remains
of the colon deers that were killed by
hellbrimp started coming back to life
and biting them over to meliotis whose
power is being absorbed by moleskilla
spell and then used to empower the
skeletons
this isn't enough though and the
skeletons are dealt with by the sins
it looks like it's over but then dien
gets mind controlled through the grudges
of the people that helbram had
slaughtered the spirits end up raising
her power level to 48
000 and she starts attacking the other
sins helgren then appears to take
responsibility for killing all those
people in colin d
king's helmet where halbroom's soul
resided is crushed by dien and after
that the corrupted aura starts to go
away a bit some of the souls still
aren't satisfied though and this forces
elizabeth to step in casting a spell to
purge them
episode well elizabeth heals everybody
that was injured in the fighting and
after that approaches merlin saying that
she knew her when she was around 12 or
13.
muleskule suddenly shows up and turns
into a massive cobra to fight the sins
she targets band first since he was the
one that cost her six of her seven
hearts
o wayne sees bannon danger causing her
power to spike to 21 050
and allowing her to save him militis had
managed to break free but had to unleash
all of his power to do so
completely reverting to his old persona
apparently he had switched to his
assault mode which is something even the
10 commandments feared would happen when
he was still their leader
eskenore volunteers his services and
merlin locks him inside her perfect q
power with meliotis while eskenore and
meliodas fight to see who's stronger
moleskula takes advantage of the
opportunity to attack the others
she is quickly defeated but merlin says
the reason she lost
is because she didn't fight with her
true power elaine is prepared to die in
order to kill moleskula but elizabeth
stops them and instead uses her power to
neutralize molluscula's miasma
this turns her into a cute little snake
and merlin captures her
as well as getting rid of the
dimensional distortion i'm gonna be
doing part two and you can find that in
the left side whenever i'm finished with
it or you can check out all the seven
deadly sins recaps in the playlist on
the right side you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing i hate more than intros is
outros